here comes the intro
here we are this is great
refueling that's fine I started it I
started us on this screen I've been busy
while you were gone by the way um Mike
got some refreshments I studied this and
realized that I've been thinking about
it wrong I think for some reason I got
at my head that a and B makes C that's
not the case that's the only thing
you've been thinking about wrong I
that's true well no I learned some other
stuff I read these books check this out
and realize this if you repeatedly
create the same kind of ammo your skill
will be improved and you'll be able to
create more powerful ammunition which is
really rad that information plus the
fact that we have never gotten C yet
thus there's no reason to combine a and
C B and C in such and such I think we
should just be [ __ ] making bullets
here yeah because you're not gonna just
give me an influx of C and no more a and
B I think we're gonna get all of it so I
think I should just like be going here
so as I said I've been busy I went ahead
and got the reloading tool and all of
all the gunpowder somebody just see what
we're working with we have three A and
one B and that's it okay so I thought
maybe we should start making me bully
it's okay now the down side of this is I
saved while you were gone off the show
so we will have to remake all these
[ __ ] bullets if I die but that won't
happen so okay I think we're good so you
want me to just start making stuff or do
you think we can probably keep one a I
don't think I need like I don't know how
much I need but I I would really like
more shotgun shells I think yeah um
you only have one B that was it and then
I had three eggs so I was thinking two
A's and keep one does that sound good
sure in case you wanna make like grenade
launcher rounds later just in case so
I'll show you oh I am injured in the
last episode I screwed up royally so my
big dumb dumb do you think I should keep
these shotgun shells with me or not I'll
put this away I'll put this away I will
keep that I'm keeping that ammo pretty
sure you have some stuff coming up but I
also while you were gone did some more
stuff I don't think you need the cranker
I combined red and green twice I still
have three green know where the crank go
the rest of crank is here okay you don't
need that right now I have it and I have
this power cable so if I need any of
that stuff I need to bring it with me
right now
other than that I was thinking I'll take
one herb and I should just saved when I
finished all this stuff I'm so dumb well
you thing about this lockpick yeah bring
a lockpick okay and then do you think I
should bring shotgun shells I'm gonna
combine these so I actually have three
slots okay so you think it's through you
go into the restaurant nearby it's great
as no it has one exit and one entrance
both of which are in this part of
downtown so you're gonna be coming by
the safe room no matter what so probably
okay rather than like quest items like
the power cable or lockpick I think
bring a lockpick that might be the most
useful one okay so I will bring the
shotgun shells then I'll have two slots
if I do that so even that like though
these cutscene rooms have had a lot I
wouldn't even
I would just okay not gun shells alright
I will trust your judgment and the worst
thing that happens is if I die we have
to repress all those bullets like I
don't I'm not gonna lose that much
progress also I won't die
okay so yeah I found a a crank and I
investigated it also not while we were
recording and I found out it was a I
thought I heard a dog I'm like paranoid
about dogs
it was a hexagon crank I don't know what
that means yet but it'll fix into it
remember from the earlier games they fit
into hexagonal shape so are we going to
the right or sorry to her left into the
restaurant yes okay here we go sure
click on these boxes underneath and that
is what door are you going first I don't
know it at this point I bet it does
screw it just do it just do it just do
it sounds like a next pop song yeah
what's his name check that metal case
you're right yeah a crowbar show ticket
ye what sapphire hub he's done resonable
to to open a manhole that's right so
keep an eye out for manholes I always do
Jill does too she looks so different
than she did in the first game I feel
like that steam is gonna hurt you I you
know [ __ ] it you just saved go for it
really yeah I shoot them though that's
gonna investigate Oh God so maybe don't
fire your weapon in here at all okay so
maybe the fire hook works there
doesn't let me switch it though I'm just
gonna check out this room before I go
into the manhole you know that lamp is
lit sorry can I turn it off no I'm just
saying it's got fire right I'd like to
observe what I'm walking into here
what's that locked door is that the is
that the manhole yeah dude I don't want
to read this whole thing the tracks of
our City Hall
please don't in 1992 I was 12 years old
1982 you were not not 36 older than you
dumb [ __ ] ma'am
okay cool I'm glad we did not parse data
it could've been useful information
we'll never know that's the thing about
information you never know you get into
that booth when you don't learn you
actually never know if it could have
helped you who designed this restaurant
because you didn't know I've since
stopped caring about information booth
okay get off unnerved about this whole
area because there's nothing to do in
here and there's nothing in here so why
did they make it so what's wrong with
taking the back street
stop I don't know no you know what I'd
like to do I'd like to just take the
[ __ ] back sure no I would like up in the
manhole yeah take it hopefully that
doesn't make you go down the manhole hey
don't open it well I'd like to take this
precious gunpowder out of here now and
the reason for that is is
this whole area seems dangerous to me
because I can't shoot in here so that
makes me feel like at some point they're
gonna put zoms in here and I won't be
able to shoot I'll have to run away so I
would just I was just assuming that gas
had flooded the entire building I have
no idea I mean it definitely seems oh I
was [ __ ] just in there what's your
name
Jim did you just say you belong to
umbrellas army yeah we came all the way
out here to save you civilians but the
mission went bad the minute we landed so
that's guys think that's that's like the
storyline I shouldn't open up the show I
shouldn't open up the manhole they just
the manhole
so with memories I run into the basement
no runs the basement okay
hide in the kitchen I believe you uh
that's fighting him and I think Carlos
can help you so each time you fight him
you get like a weapon part but I don't
we don't have to do that I don't think
oh you should run
since when were you injured I've been
injured but yeah keep running your Dory
this is filling this is filling with
water yeah I know
was there a door or is that leading back
up also is the water filling while I'm
in here like [ __ ]
go talk to Carlos maybe he's up to oh
come on what the nemesis run away maybe
no I have to remake all this bliss
[Music]
what was I supposed to do differently
that wasn't weird scenario like I
I'm really glad we saved I was smart
there's no way I would have made that
out alive damn okay I'm confused but
whatever figured out great that sucks
[Music]
correct
interesting oh that's an engraving right
there they're kind of big that's my
concern right now nothing else I can
worry about um we need a better game
plan like I guess I can run away from
him but to what end I mean like what am
i I'm such a butt face look at this I
have to read you all this [ __ ] should
why don't I just save later Mary I'm
filled with regrets um I mean I don't
have to do all this again right like how
many bullets do I really need I wouldn't
you know you're not gonna use bullets we
don't want to fight nemesis awkward I
had to fight him how did you not fight
him there wasn't anything else we could
do it was like I'm fairly certain you
just missed something in the basement
and you didn't do it fast enough what am
I supposed to do in the basement there
was nothing in there riddle me this just
try the base million fine
you just make shotgun shells no those
were in there get more ammo
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna open this up
one more time because I actually am
confused now I thought I waited to make
bullets for you
yeah cuz there's B yeah so I have like
not a lot of handgun ammo so we couldn't
make that here's another option what if
in the basement I needed this this
[ __ ] crank you don't I or something
yeah so why just do something I just
missed something
alright so what do I need here I think I
should take some health I wouldn't bring
the shotgun shells I don't think why I
need to shoot that [ __ ] if you find
something Bassman you not gonna have to
fight the nemesis like that's the whole
point of those live selections is that
you ones escape one is fight and
pressure but I didn't remember yours
gonna fight with Carlos well I'm not
trust your judgement but if I die you
try fighting if you want you have Carlos
to help you out now but I don't think
you want to okay I'll trust your
judgment um if I die again though I'm
gonna fight him or something I obviously
need a different tactic right yeah so oh
that was you holy [ __ ] well you know
like when you slow your voice down
enough where you can hear like the
actual flickering of your throat yeah I
get it that's a voice
I've got resin evil four or five six the
ps4 copy is sitting on my desk right now
alright
that's a patient of being this game so
we're going with this again should I get
those um gunpowder tzatzi's or should I
not
yeah get them get them okay so what if I
shot behind bad can you go back yeah you
maybe turn around oh no nevermind what
do you want me to do I was thinking you
can go behind the counter I don't know
if you can duck would you come down
there
so like what if the thing is I'm just
supposed to shoot him like I know you
don't have to fight them what if I just
did that I'm sure that would help
you'd have to match the Dodge and these
tight corners though I feel like he'd
kill me
alright so I'm getting this stuff real
fast city guide will go and welcome to
our beautiful city it was founded in
nineteen Diggity - all right so we're
just gonna do this again oh it's not
there Mike mmm interesting does this
game implement use it or lose it
where the [ __ ] is my powder it sound
like a coke addict where is it
the [ __ ] is my powder is it evil give me
my [ __ ] pattern no seriously though
no no it's pretty terrifying though if
we just lost 30 bullets that's huge all
right what am i doing say wait when you
restarted was your did you have your
inventory like I don't know I don't have
it all right so I'm opening this again
yeah and like the basement and I'm
choosing to go down there when he comes
and search the wall more thoroughly
search I just checked I look this up
because I knew there was something down
there but I don't want you to like [ __ ]
up over and over again I won't not [ __ ]
up but alright I also didn't wanna like
screw us over in the long run all right
God knows what's that it's me Carlos
zombie
my name's Carlos corporal of umbrellas
biohazard countermeasure force what's
your name
Jim did you just say you belong to
umbrellas army yeah we came all the way
out here to save you civilians but the
mission went bad the minute we landed
yours all right what am i doing
basement okay
this way there's gonna be all rights to
go along the wall okay there's a lot of
walls so turn the corner okay
so here
damn I just barely missed it
yeah excuse me Carlos okay bye Carlos
yeah see you loser how did you get out
wait I have to ask you something I know
you want to ask me out
Oh crazy my god yeah it does keep
dreaming
tell me wait is this like an umbrella
send your team in we're here to rescue
the civilians don't lie to me
umbrella is the reason why this whole
mess began look we're just mercenaries
hired hands do you really think the
master would tell his dogs why'd have to
retrieve the stick he just threw
if you want answers you should talk to
someone else I am NOT with umbrella but
he just said he was alone hope we'll
have to finish this later
believe it or not we're only here to
rescue the civilians if you can trust me
then safe runs back this way I can't
move he just won't shut up Carlos yeah
we just go sit back to the safe room
yeah I could probably kill those guys
you saw the other door to go through so
I would wait around deposit what I
didn't get my [ __ ] powder I'm
actually really mad
your ego it's not in the air [ __ ] it
doesn't matter I want the other ones
like
it's just like impossible that they
would be such pricks about that or maybe
not it's not that crazy just makes me
mad all right what am i doing going to
the other what other doorway so I've
been into there I haven't been through
yeah so I'll even newspaper office my
girl takes a right way to search this
whole room I thought I did I found oh I
also found shotgun shells while you were
gone [ __ ] you you [ __ ] oh my god
thank God you made those bullets god I
didn't save
you don't worry about saying just do the
restaurant again really fast and then
you just go to the newspaper oh this is
the worst episode man this game is not
forgiving I just thought we just I
thought I was safe I like didn't it kind
of like walked over me while I was
trying to get better we're like trying
to get up at least it's really kind of
hurry up in the newspaper office geez
geez should I save again no I wouldn't
well maybe it's like kind of burning
through some time here all right
we're learning should I combine bullets
or not che cuz you're that you might not
come back here you [ __ ] you could do
the restaurant like two seconds now
I'm just gonna try to do this really
fast it's like this whole episode has
basically been me combining bullets and
dying and it's really just like just
disheartens empty also seven fit in the
shotgun so that's actually perfect okay
and then I need health I forgot about
that I am like super disappointed
remember what I said at the beginning
this episode no I said damn I did a lot
of stuff after I saved which is pretty
dumb but I won't die and I've spent this
whole episode dying here we find
ourselves so if I kill him how long did
it take before he comes back he just
won't chase you for the rest of this
section I think but it makes me just
want to kill him I just don't know if I
can you have to be pretty good at
dodging otherwise use a magnum rounds
name and Carlos will help you but still
good I like a little freaked out I
finally met my maker here like I can't I
might have a really hard time living the
newspaper office should I not go back to
the save room I would just keep going
yet like just run mmm like a mother okay
check the room anyway see see if my
powders there I'm mad I do not like that
what hmm is it because I made like I
don't know idea
it's very confusing but yeah even if you
stop by to deposit those you're gonna
have to pick up stuff in the newspaper
office you don't have room I know so now
I have to go to the save room like now
that I know he's gonna be there I think
I'm a little bit more prepared to dodge
him like I was not ready for that
I like didn't I thought I had more time
yeah I don't know this whole thing is
like could say back there if you wanted
to you think if you wanted to I don't
know really fast save it's like saving
after like five minutes of work
well now it's like [ __ ] 30 minutes of
work because it's taken so goddamn long
keep dying well what you know what
you're doing yeah you know hey Carlos oh
I like what you're packing hit me like
it was always like that with the Tomb
Raider - like I would spend hours on a
Tomb Raider level and if I died and I
had to like redo it took me like five
minutes to get through it cuz they knew
the puzzle all of a sudden these aren't
really puzzle based but
[Music]
run [ __ ] wait I'm a big weenie right
okay
manhole say vroom Dodge that sounded
like a good plan
yeah and if it doesn't work we won't
talk about it
that's all you could do the newspaper
August first if this doesn't work if you
wanted to I think that's harder though
what harder come on
such a cruel game
wait all the ladies love it all the
ladies love it
I could skip those drives them crazy
what keep dreaming yeah no seriously
tell me why did umbrella send your team
in we're here to rescue the civilians
don't lie to me it's pretty long
cutscene that's right look we're just
mercenaries hired hands my eyes are up
here keep your hands off my tube top
mister I don't trust you at all keep
your hands off my kneepads possibly Rock
and more cleave than I am
believe it or not we're only here to
rescue the civilians if you can trust me
then help us think about it see you
later
[Music]
alright so let me make this clear
I just gotta get to that door right the
one up that stairs it's all I gotta do
yeah okay I think I can do this
you also heal with a green herb right
now if you want what that's a bad idea
you could say if you want to although I
don't I wouldn't do that because we
could if you do die we could you could
try out the newspaper office first I'm
gonna I'm gonna heal I think that's a
great idea I'm gonna do one heal nope
Shep huh I'm gonna open at this box I'm
gonna do one heal just to get out of
caution god damn it
[ __ ] game it's annoying
I'm ready I'm ready all right I'm not
ready okay that worked out really well a
little urgency throughout these this
next alleyway so I had dodged because I
thought I would need it but yeah just go
straight to the newspaper office you can
come back here later okay so straight
into the right nope
to the right and then to the left
because I got to go in that yellow door
yeah okay here we go
I think that I don't want to die I don't
want to die you mean the yellow one no
no this this one you get online from
this side here we go do it stars now
he's gonna break in though right you
might have to do some dodging while you
like look for items and [ __ ] the music
is gone just scan this room really quick
while he's not here the music will come
back that when he comes through okay
there's nothing in I what do you mean
oh my god it's locked maybe a lockpick
door oh I'm gonna do that oh wait oh you
need the crank for this part you know no
no we didn't need it you can dodge music
if you get back to the table where is I
think I think I'm pretty positive on
just search the room anyway just he's
gonna come in I don't just we don't have
a choice right now so check up on you
have a coffee positive you need to crank
it sweet person who took that's dead
scoop scoop Jardine old Serkis
basketball player anyway oh wait no no
no okay hold on
no yeah nevermind you can just use this
ladder I remember there being a really
dumb lever in this game that doesn't
make sense
that's the keel thing or something he'll
I'm taking it I actually think you're
safe I don't think they'd make you do an
environmental puzzle if they're pretty
good about that aren't they what yeah
run into it for a few seconds what do
you mean oh it push it oh really I think
got it to where it's that button on the
wall not that one
oh all the way up there I know it dumb
right I think this is what I was
thinking oh my no there's a really dumb
button in this game that no one whatever
like why the [ __ ] would you put that
button there sorry I'm having trouble
getting her to do what I want her to do
I'm just as frustrated see like just do
the thing [ __ ] there we go sorry I'm
sorry I yelled at you me no her not
sorry for anything about you there's no
power going to the switchboard will you
turn on the power
now what this opens yeah can I look at
them out
um is there like a button mm-hmm it
doesn't look like a button yeah
Oh balls
can I run just take the left side I
guess I don't think it's gonna burn you
I hope not yeah [ __ ] horseshit oh I
try that door it might just not let you
go through I don't think you want to go
in there like it's not okay nevermind
cool moves any risky choice in tonight
crap can I go through it now
sorry I I just like want to know where
I'm going so that if I have to turn
around and run like hell backwards I can
that's like where my brain is at any job
openings please don't have that guy in
here I don't want to deal with it oh god
it's a hallway those are the worst okay
reading material oh I thought that was
sparkling but it's not up there where I
don't know just in the room got it
that's a gym cool now I got a blue one
and a green one
oh [ __ ] dodge him for no no or
180-degree no move what are you doing I
can't it wasn't a cutscene that was real
time I figured that you'd probably heal
I know I'm in fire dude
heal and then just heal and then run
into that room what room where you came
from
why do you don't have any items that are
gonna let you progress right now there's
got to be a way through there
no it's there's literally there's no
point coming into here if you don't find
something else no he will kill me just
just dodge him like there's there's
something in there like there be no
other points coming through you gotta
get I got the gym the gyms not like a
gonna be like a I'm I think you should
double-check in there he'll be fine
dodging yeah just do the 180 degrees I
didn't it didn't
it didn't work thank God okay got a
zombie and I got that [ __ ] now at
least I'm fine
so I gotta go back in there I think so
I'm pretty sure there's like a key item
you didn't get he's gonna kill me he
might not even be in there we go back I
don't think he like stays in a specific
does I think yeah stop he just like he's
so good at grabbing me honestly 6260 get
right back to zombie
there's no item at night you thought I
would heels you might as well now no go
back down this way go down there you're
gonna at this point you're gonna die you
might as well check to check around oh
man there's something on that desk right
there no there's not there are promises
of evidence plant picking me up just
kicking the [ __ ] out of here I think
there's something behind it no it's not
leave the building I guess you should
just die Susan what do you even have now
rather I'm gonna check really quick
while you recover I just want to make
sure that we're not like I read
somewhere that if you look at a door he
doesn't come through it so I'm safe as
long as the store is in my angle but
once I go down these stairs he'll
probably come through the door okay oh
my god this is like the worst this
probably might be the worst episode yeah
whatever I could not Juke that [ __ ]
he's so big am I getting worse my heart
breaking mm-hmm
take a load off Jill dude it's probably
gem related we're good just stuck
between his zombie and that dude yeah I
guess the green gem is but I hate you I
like gotten so much more I fall for
falling
I am and I am so [ __ ] for health
oh my god what my doing good start over
now that we know we're doing I guess
just explore this area while he's
chasing you to figure out where you
going
I cannot explore this area he's going to
kill me oh yeah the gems yeah okay so
that makes sense now you might as well
just wipe and do all this are you
serious do you think I should kill
myself and do this whole goddamn thing
again 100 percent yeah cuz now you know
you're doing you could have gotten the
green gem again ow ow what did I lose I
lost two health kits full health kits if
you want to continue go for it you still
need to go get the blue gem first though
this goddamn no you could wipe and do it
so much better
- do it way better bring the blue gem
whether you see don't they go back to
the safe room yeah like I've learned a
lot mm-hmm
alright I wasn't helping but like i said
i'm i can't guide you through this game
that much right you haven't I know
alright let me kill myself yeah what now
they're not there okay um let's go to
the safe room come out there you go
hello I'm gonna try to Juke him okay so
that didn't work
juking him is really hard you know that
yeah I think you want to try to go to
the side with his unsaved shirt because
that's he always hits you with his left
hand you want to go the other way
his soft hand yeah yeah all right so
three deaths in one episode is probably
the most we've ever had but I feel
really confident it's gonna happen in
this game that I know what to do now
this probably not be the worst episode
oh come on big socks
they're gonna make it stars hunting
machine then it's kind of death
perception he hates my guts
correct oh it's been such a such a
gut-wrenching experience for me to just
constantly die and lose so now so now
I'm thinking you could probably do it so
you don't have to go back to the save
room to deposit those I like getting
flashbacks to the last episode to you
member in the last episode I like I
wouldn't even worry about stuff right
now don't know don't make bullets so
listen I think I don't the reason the
Gunpowder was there such a stretch was
because I made bullets I don't think
that it makes any sense at all you do it
I am in a superstition I am I am so
yeah it's a box all right put obviously
that in the pucks away neither lockpick
put the shotgun away okay
bring the blue gem chip bring a blue gem
that's it okay so now you don't have to
go back to the save room at all he'll be
easier to yeah good
we will have made progress in this
episode oh it's actually been just a
little heartbreaking I do not want to
see this cutscene again where he's like
I know you won't ask me out it's too hot
it's coming though we both know what's
happening I turn the volume down we can
ad-lib it let's do it
alright you might be Carlos you're going
to oh yeah I forgot it's not start I'm
Joe you're dumb
alright check for those fresh powers but
I don't think I am gonna check for the
first pow
and I think it's gonna be there I don't
think the like logic that you're it's a
resonable game they're not gonna make
you're gonna be able to stockpile stuff
it's just like logic says no I don't
think that has anything to do with the
way you thought it does it so now you
can get the green gem oh wait there's
health in there too I didn't bring
health with me oh god yes you know yes
so you just need enough to kill that
first Dombey and get the green gem and
get out of there No oh my god it'll be
fine just go do this or don't do this
yet and if you like the news first no no
it's gonna be the same thing the gem
will be when these things happen it's
like the items will be in the other
building no I'm saying go back to the
same if you didn't have what you need to
go back to the safe box too late now
what's that oh now I'm car
I'm Jill oh hey I didn't see you there
girl friend I'm still talking my manager
they left but he said something's been
going on outside I've just been working
but no one's here stay under my arms
I'll protect you
so hot right now everybody loves my hot
guns
that sounds pretty gross I don't want to
be in your armpit Wow who is that who is
that he found us whatever that's just
pretty bad a blue it's not living and
honestly if I die again we should do
something weird cuz like I like don't
know what to say right now I'm so
defeated I just feel broken
you could deposit [ __ ] in the safe box
and try dodging him again but this point
I see I did successfully last time but I
think I got really lucky
remember hug the far left wall I don't
know we can figure that out one
cuz like going through the save box
offers this nice bonus where I can get
rid of those pals if you want to and
then I can get the health and the gem
wait where did you get that vest well I
wasn't ready for that
so Adlon is JCPenney well I got this top
on sale but my again my manager is not
here I haven't gotten paid all week
screw your manager screw my manager my
manager is my dad he he's been yelling
at me and telling shut up I don't care
about your dad
you can call me Dad
from now on cuz that's my name okay
look like the game froze did you just
how I talk now shut up
why does your hair look like an open
book oh there's my manager
well done give me a senior manager no no
he's coming he's really nice y'all I've
got bigger things to do right now I'm
gonna leave right now through this nice
tube top let me know where it's at wait
okay hey Dad you this is my boyfriend
Carlos we're hitting the music back on
before we lose all of the people who
watch the show I don't take any like
ad-lib classes of any kind
clearly improv yeah I just talked you
the talk should I take a health in case
he touches me sure
get ready dude you could heal right now
she wants you I feel pretty good the
likelihood of him doing the tongue thing
to your face at the will of your face
like increases the lower your health is
all right just dodged left ball you got
me Oh and he threw me the wrong way this
is unfortunately okay don't worry we're
good no come on
what they supposed to go that left what
they supposed to go the left like I'm in
an alley I like don't have a lot of
options here newspaper building up great
it stirs that dead body on the way out
if you have time have some time yeah
just push this clattering [ __ ] I think
I'm gonna use the same amount of Health
the first day it's very there no you
don't use the if you don't use anything
upstairs you'll be fine
you can hurry up and get the green jam
before he gets that I doubt it I mean
you got a you got a really master the
like Juke yeah like he's too big I don't
know who's gonna press r1 right before
he does I think no I tried it on the
last one when I knew I was gonna die
anyway and r1 didn't work for him I mean
it's the same button I know but it
didn't work that's definitely one thing
before we keep going the game
I shouldn't research listen nobody's
more upset about this than me upset
it's gonna happen in this game I just
feel like I'm a loser like I can't do
this I don't want to like he's here no
he's here I heard his music would be on
there's gonna be whenever he's hunting
you this is the most scary of all the
Resident Evil games we've ever played
like it really is I'm freaking out all
the time I'm really upset okay we'll be
fine
going can wear just the gem that was too
fast I get the jam right there it's
right there and then just get the [ __ ]
out okay
all right okay just leave yeah nope yes
yes
nice good good guess fighting at the
beginning alleviates this but I don't
know if you have okay hate that guy
alright I'm fine okay we know how to do
this mm-hmm so we just run like hell to
that big door the bottom line and we're
going back to the safe room yeah no you
go to the gym door at the bottom left
that's why we um where's that that's the
only other girl just go outside and then
go down to the bottom left he won't he
won't okay go
we should I ran downstairs faster yeah
she's slow [ __ ]
he will he attack me while I'm putting
gems in he could no just hurry I mean
quick button
probably matters where you put it right
I don't know
yeah but to what ends like well let kill
that guy
and let me in let me in let me in let me
in let me in let me in let me in the
music's over we do it no he's gonna the
music no he's gonna keep punting you
until no the game's over we did it what
do you think he's gonna keep hunting you
I don't know check that room out I guess
in case it's a lot me to check the map
you have the map so you should have a
good beeline to a good safe room like
just pan over you just like want to save
now
oh my god it's behind me is the closest
one yeah I know that's the closest one
but the trolley wait so that looks like
it's blocked so I don't think you get to
the gas station yet no so it's like
you're aiming for the trolley which is a
while low so so I could do like a little
loop-d-loop here I could go straight
take a right yeah if you watch my
crosshairs right like if I go straight
to a right go up say vroom thoughts um
feelings I mean there might be one
that's just not on the map yeah I'm
wondering cuz no you have a downtown map
you could go back and I could do the
same thing no I'm worried that when you
go through that alleyway door the right
he's gonna be in the alley won't build a
Dodge this alley no it's the right to
get back to that close to saving room oh
and here might go
got my [ __ ] heart broken soul I'm a
broken soul I I really don't want to do
this again I don't want to die I have
health you could just go to save room if
you want like I think we should go back
if you want I think we should go
straight and up and then go like this
that's blocked I think you're not gonna
be you can't get that's not gonna get
you back to that safe room why not
because look that's blocked well where's
the yellow thing go then I don't know
I'm just saying it looks blocked it I'm
saying that's not even if you get into
that hallway that's blocked off that's
what that diagonal line is you have to
go to a different safe room if you don't
do that what do you think I should do
and I'm I'm going for it keep I would
say just make a beeline to the trolley
which we know is gonna be another
where's the trolley right there okay so
you let me go down you're gonna have to
dodge let me go down here and then
laughs great some things say for a while
but I'm taking the left route and I'm
going through here mm-hmm
it's either that or a turn around I
don't know if you want to turn around
cuz he's really gonna be in this
alleyway why just shook him you can try
if you want but then on the way out of
the safe room you're gonna dodge him
again yeah it's up to you then do that I
don't know we can go we can keep going I
wouldn't do that but you wouldn't keep
going
I would keep going I wouldn't double oh
well then let's keep going but yeah I
definitely go bottom let's just go to
beat make a beeline for the trolley
right you're gonna have to dodge some
regular zombies I'm pretty sure sure of
course I hurry like you're standing
still while he's about to come through
he can't come through because I'm
looking at the door right now he can't
but I'm still it's still like you keep
going there I guess check that out make
sure you can open stirs fart we he might
not be done hunting you but just the
music being off doesn't okay so
I think he's done I think this music
bass music never starts until he busts
into the just go for the Charlie Stars
I'm gonna like clap and laugh when he
shows up stars I keep saying that no
because he says that star stars there's
a medieval door [ __ ] die
good dodge this dude you die okay oh
[ __ ] that was my bad it's fine so I'm
going to the right and then to that
yellow thing it's not even the righteous
straight okay [ __ ] hell
strong caution
oh this is dangerous you have no other
thing check it out I'm like I've been so
unlucky and this money thing alright I
think you're gonna pick anything off
your something
throw me a [ __ ] bone here that bone
for the dog nice sweet [ __ ] it take them
both actually
no you're gonna have to come back this
way I would save in case there's like
key items up ahead
you know I have to double back on it
just get on the way back am I gonna go
to the trolley when I get through this
door a bike just go to the [ __ ]
trolley Mary
see what's in it maybe you'll meet the
Carlos's brother up here I should the
barrel probably at this point just [ __ ]
it [ __ ]
hopefully you killed more than just one
dog sucking dick he stupid dog I am not
having it
thank you a shot on my neck side anyway
shot the barrel and I said yeah
yeah you got a couple dogs sweet
that doors lock it is yep okay doesn't
seem like he's hunting you so come back
down this way like check this area yeah
okay so that's their what is the red
barrel right oh yeah should check that
clock see what's up whatever what human
go no I think it's if it's a blue room
it's a cutscene I really hope you don't
need the power probably need the power
cord I know that you're you know what
let's not take the time to read this
whole thing I'm not doing it
What's Wrong bill fix it you probably
need the power card just yeah you need
the power cord and the fuses okay well
okay so good we're not like right power
cord fuse oil power card fuse oil so
just go through the trolley door right
now it's good to know from the rescue
team right I just ran into your teammate
Carlos oh he was a piece of work hey I'm
no ordinary City I'm the member of Stars
stars
you win the RPGs special force team
hey is someone wounded back there
thanks Jill get ready I'm no doctor
everything is gonna be okay any closer
I'm like I can't breathe ever
Carlos she's not even looking at him
she's got a camera yeah we can trust
I love when she puts her hand her head
sergeant I mean Oh business units down
to you me and lieutenant Kyle that's it
and my house hurt bad if we don't
cooperate we won't be walking away from
this mission
yeah old Butthead he looks like the
soldier from soldier 76 then let's go
over every soldier from overwatch we are
moving to the Clocktower area which is
the designated landing zone for the
extraction chopper I'm feeling spry once
we get there and give the signal the
chopper will fly in and pull us out
that's a lot of ground to cover
I don't think we can make it on foot the
main problem we have is that the landing
zone is cut off from here by the fire so
we have no choice but to use this cable
car to navigate through it fortunately
we can also use it as a moving shield to
get us through the worst areas that
works for me
good plan sir okay people let's good
have been good at the power cord you see
it on two ha ha have it your story later
this song
by Emmer's there's bigger inventory back
maybe Oh more inventory book yeah
alright sweet its holster and there was
something shiny here oh [ __ ] sweet for
the bolts and then you get the fire hose
and you go through that door okay so now
you're looking for the power cord you
look for oil fuse I [ __ ] I want a
[ __ ] save so bad not funny like I
don't think I've ever wanted to save
more of my life alright yeah just
beeline for the same room I like I'm
actually I'm freaking out I just like
got a first sales break I just want to
live music just go back to say bro let's
go fine little heart
you got a zombie on the ground and a
zombie to dodge unless the nemesis comes
oh okay so I'm taking a right and then a
left yeah just go back where you came
I literally came from do not do this
alright please please don't show up
let's just jump this jump
he's on fire now you might be able to
jump that uh okay it worked itself out
mm-hmm come on memories
hopefully burns to death before you get
back there I don't think you will oh I'm
taking it oh you bet your buns I'm
taking that sweet way more amatory space
that's good yeah it's really good I mean
let me just look at my map all right so
this one's a straight one but there's a
zombie in here and Lily's going straight
but their turn you have to worry about
no there's no zombie here it's in the
next one
Oh unless they place the zombie here but
yeah just so like let's just be clear
straight straight straight straight
yeah it's just I'll tell you where you
go don't worry buddy stop over your map
why I panic I know it stop there's no
zombies here I'm gonna freak out I'm
gonna freak out I'm the one who could
lose it all here okay like we're having
the first day of spray in a green herb
even if he hits you a few times of fine
that dude might I just feel better
opening up my mouth go all the way down
stop opening your mouth I'll tie you up
you're fine he's dead nice [ __ ] you heal
up heal up he'll use it just one green
herbs fine why don't I just wait until
he hits me again he's about to grab you
from behind your neck available there
you go just don't I just want that one
make sure he from behind
you're gonna come back actually oh [ __ ]
nice nice nice nice nice this job [ __ ]
you guys here's one gram that wasn't bad
could've been worse you could have run
to one of those dudes to get tossed
around an idiot circle it's just a term
of my calling idiot all right
hooker right go straight like a
[ __ ] go about that no I'm in a
cautious fine alright there were herbs
in there there like nothing in this game
everything is just such [ __ ] right now
right across then saver
just suck it he's in this alleyway
seriously I will like I'll be so mad on
the way back there you can be prepared
for that you can bring a shotgun [ __ ]
he's not gonna be in here good I love
how that you do the little red herring
like misdirection in the broken windows
[ __ ] it who cares let him die not my
problem
all right sweet save it up I have never
been this stressed out no save now
playing this game like this is just like
got wrenchingly scary I'm frightened
save ribbons
these girls keep plowing through you
wanna do another one all right um a lot
done
what do I need for the next one because
I might offer like the next area the
wrench that's it I don't know if that's
it I would take a lockpick in case
you've needed that a lot more than
everything else power chord you know you
don't need yeah those not yet yes yeah
cool sweet oh that was just devastating
they're gonna happen we do have to get
we have some bad episode we did have
some progression some valleys to make
the peaks better do all right here we go
definitely the down moment but it
happens you came out you came out of
life
morale is low got some health morale is
low well you got the two powders you
didn't use yet that's good that's what
how many hang on rounds 30 30 all right
sweet thanks guys for watching Mary's
gonna go cry disappointed with myself
it's like heartbreaking I'm a loser so
why don't you kill me
you